hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast dad I'm just checking on you
just checking in on you I'm officially
out of ways to say that there's a hole
in there's a hole in the wall in this
[ __ ] room
these guys fix the pipes because there
was galvanized piping in here and I
never got this hole fixed just [ __ ]
realize that that's how [ __ ] up my
house is you know what I realize I talk
about my house so much that there's
somebody sitting there going like
eventually he's gonna run out of money
probably right when the house is 98%
fixed and I'm gonna swoop in and buy it
and he's gone in and redone everything
redid everything speaking of which I got
the epoxy floor puttin on my gym I went
downstairs to look at it I was like oh
boy oh boy would you look at that floor
you can't eat up oh boy oh boy and I
went in there buh buh buh boom Wow it
was bubbles
so they gotta add another layer because
you know my floor is not level they're
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] we've got to flow
up the floor that's gonna cost you all
this money maybe we do filling the crack
another grand out the window see I
didn't care anymore I just laughs now
when contractors come up to me what do
you want what do you it's like that old
Robin Williams story that if you just
walked up to him at some point you said
hey man Robin I'm a comedian he would
just write you a check for a hundred
bucks hey sorry sorry if I rift on some
of your [ __ ] my apologies this is what I
do now in contractors show up yeah I
know how much this time okay I just go
into my pocket or do I need the
checkbook do I got to write numbers on a
piece of paper just never ends
it never ends and meanwhile meanwhile as
I wait for the gym to be made I am
sitting in the writers room doing
efforts for family and two things have
happened i'm i'm putting on writers room
wait my gym isn't [ __ ] made and
you know I'm [ __ ] I feel like the
last I don't know if I've talked to you
guys both my [ __ ] left leg my
hamstrings like tightened up you know
you ever see the guy run down the first
baseline Nelson hey hey that's [ __ ]
hoppin oh that guy in the Celtics in
Game one yeah running up the court he
just [ __ ] collapses I was like God did
I did I literally pull a hamstring doing
stand-up because God knows I haven't
been working out and and you know what I
ended up figuring it out what it was is
it's from sitting down in the [ __ ]
writers room like I guess sitting is not
healthy it's one of the most unhealthy
things you could do I guess your body's
not designed the way that we sit the way
that we've made chairs just plop your
ass down whatever it is blood flow I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is
so all [ __ ] Billy buttcheeks here now
I got a problem with my [ __ ] sciatic
nerve on my left side so I literally had
to have my lovely wife buy one of those
foam rollers right sitting all right and
literally I looked up some lay on the
[ __ ] internet who had like I looked
up the proper way to do it before I did
it because I know that you can [ __ ] your
body up like people get these things and
they just start rolling around on them
and I immediately learned first thing
you don't wanna roll over joints there's
all this [ __ ] there's all this proper
form so I went through about two or
three videos till I got to somebody who
all the comments were like oh my god
your forms perfect and all that so I was
I was watching this woman so basically
what I do is I sit down on the thing and
then cross my legs as she says cowboy
style not ladylike cowboy style which is
basically like if I was wearing a skirt
my balls would be hanging out right
sorry visual you sit like that and then
you sort of put your weight on one side
and you and I gotta tell you dude the
[ __ ] pain that I was in it isn't like
a it it isn't like a like a severe pain
it was like the if you had an older
brother and you know when he would be
[ __ ] with you
I sort of start twisting your arm you'd
be like like that that type of a [ __ ]
pain and I got to tell you the the foam
roller is a goddamn game-changer but if
I didn't have to go in this but the
thing is I kind of work it out and it's
fine you work it out you know but then I
go and I'm in a writers room all day so
I keep trying to stand up in that type
of [ __ ] and I'm feeling like it's two
steps forward and one step back but I'm
at least moving in the right direction
so I just putting that out there if you
do have any of those types of problems
get one of those this has been working
for me I should say I'm not a doctor and
I don't play one on TV but this has been
working for me and if you're young I
would start doing yoga as soon as you
can
it's I'm telling you I I've known this
forever but I just get bored with [ __ ]
I'll do yoga I'll be like I'm just gonna
do yoga like every [ __ ] day and then
I just get burned out and then I'm like
you know what [ __ ] yoga you know I get
mad at yoga rather than myself for being
totally [ __ ] obsessed with [ __ ] for
like ten days until I just you know I
did that with Chipotle a long time ago
and I lived in New York City you know if
you haven't moved in New York City which
I hope you do everybody should try
[ __ ] live there it's great you know
until you get to your 30s and it's like
am I gonna be one of those cat people I
got to get out of here right I want some
space you know but when you live there
you know you start ordering out this
outworks you move there
you're [ __ ] terrified like how the
[ __ ] am I gonna afford to live here and
you [ __ ] eat spaghetti every [ __ ]
night right and then you start making a
little more money and every once in a
while you take a cab and you're like oh
my god I'm taking a cab this is [ __ ]
amazing and then you get back to your
apartment and you have all this guilt
because you blew all that money and you
could have just spent you know whatever
the [ __ ] it was back in the day was like
a dollar 25 to take the subway yeah I
know that's how old I am
and then you start making a little more
money then all of a sudden you start
ordering out right you start ordering
out you start to get to know all the
restaurants and all that type of [ __ ]
and then once you had the money to order
out what immediately happens is it's
just a radius within which that they'll
deliver
you burn out every [ __ ] restaurant
around you and then you become Ben
you're officially in New Yorker when
you're living in Manhattan and you're
bitching that there's no good
restaurants in your neighborhood
there's no good Italian you can't get
good Italian I don't understand there's
so many people here if the foot traffic
although I don't think putting it an
Italian [ __ ] restaurant that you
start flipping out like whatever your
favorite food is you're bitching that
it's not there so whatever so this
Chipotle ends up opening up after I
tried every [ __ ] restaurant 15 times
at my little [ __ ] three block radius
and I went to that [ __ ] thing like I
swear to God I went there like I don't
know maybe 11 days in a month I I'll
never forget how I felt that last time I
felt like I was at the end of like a
food eating contest where you were just
telling your jaw to keep moving up and
down with the rest of your body was like
can we just puke now and I don't think
I've ever I don't think I've been there
since Chipotle and Thai food it was a
Thai food restaurant down the street and
I remember I ordered it and it was
delicious and then it sat in my fridge
for two three days and I said hey you
know what I think I do I'll do I'm gonna
eat that three day old Thai food see how
that does and I got food poisoning and
rather than being the mature person and
taking the responsibility on my end I
blame Thai food I was like [ __ ] Thai
food I'm never eating Thai food again I
didn't eat that for like ten years and
then you know eventually we came back we
were we were able to smooth things over
you know like Guns and Roses you don't
to me it was the exact same thing exact
same trajectory I had with Thai food
band members and Guns and Roses had with
Axl Rose and now they're all back
together and evidently the [ __ ] shows
have been great they played Mexico City
the other night and I would have loved
to have gone down to that going to that
show had a great time then get kidnapped
you know would that be great
Mexico City scares the [ __ ] out of me
any Mexico people Mexicans real ones
real ones I don't mean the ones here in
LA I mean the real [ __ ] deal you're
in Mexico you know I mean like I'm
German Irish but I don't live in
Deutschland or [ __ ] the the Emerald
I'll you know what I mean I lived in
Massachusetts I went to friendlies you
know I'm not a kraut right so let me let
me ask you this because it's right there
it's [ __ ] a quick plane ride away
there's all these beautiful places to go
and then there's all these other
fucked-up places to go I don't know
where to go I don't know where to go and
you know all they show about you guys is
the [ __ ] drug cartels peeling
people's faces back you know and I know
there's no [ __ ] way all of Mexico
everybody's just walking around peeling
off each other's faces I know there's no
[ __ ] way that that's happening I know
there's it's like here I bet people
outside of this country think everybody
walks down the street with a [ __ ] gun
on their hip
you know when they don't have money for
a toll they shoot the guy in the
Tollbooth and then some stagecoach comes
in I don't know what the [ __ ] they think
right well they think we're in and and
we're all 300 pounds and were on [ __ ]
meth right
we don't know where England is all that
[ __ ] I like that snobby European [ __ ]
where they just think they're so [ __ ]
cultured get out of me with their little
ass [ __ ] countries over there that's
driving trip I donated if I go over to
[ __ ] Europe I love when they say [ __ ]
like that you know you guys don't know
about the [ __ ] world it's like
neither do you you don't know what the
[ __ ] going on over in Asia you know
what's going on right in your little
[ __ ] area but your little area for me
would just be the East Coast but for you
it's like 15 different [ __ ] countries
Belgium and [ __ ] Luxembourg I mean
you can walk through those two countries
you can sleepwalk through those two
countries from [ __ ] Amsterdam and end
up in France and be like well [ __ ] I got
to go to work and then jog back
having said that I'd love to go to both
places oh the big phony covered his
[ __ ] tracks oh it's gonna go to your
show in Belgium but after you talked
about how small we were now I'm not
going
controversy on social media today when
one person in Belgium took offense
so anyways they're redoing the [ __ ]
floors again so I end up getting bubbles
B is for bubbles
remember that Sesame Street bubbles
bubbles bubbles it pays for brother who
bought you some and there was that
[ __ ] guy with the puberty voice
harmonizing I think he was supposed to
sound like a beach boy type thing but it
didn't it was just [ __ ] it used to
make me like angry when I was a kid
see if I can find that for you guys and
I'll start playing it so anyways as
always I never let myself get too out of
shape and I need to drop about 10 pounds
so oh [ __ ] uh freckles here despite
the fact the gym isn't made yet and I
got to go to work everyday I'm going to
try to lose two pounds a week I'm back
up to 180 everybody and I've been eating
well the last couple of days and always
the first couple days the fact that if
you just eat well you drop a couple so I
got a Scalia said 177 so I musta ate
like a [ __ ] tub of [ __ ] the night
before when I got on at 180 so I'm about
178 so I'm just gonna go back down to
168 be right around the time for my
birthday and you know two pounds that's
easy right a couple of push-ups you know
I mean I go my stupid foam roller oh my
god I you know I'm so [ __ ] old I
think I have to bring it to work
how [ __ ] hilarious is that I'm gonna
walk in with that thing at work and and
I'm gonna walk in to a room full of
comedy writers do you understand big
pounding that I'm gonna [ __ ] take let
me get that's gonna actually [ __ ] up our
work for today because I'm gonna spend
the first two hours trashing me and what
am I gonna do other than [ __ ] take it
that's it there's nothing I can [ __ ]
do oh by the way by the way is I'm all
over the [ __ ] map here did you
[ __ ] see that shameless [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton trying to pander to get
the african-american vote she saw some
radio show I just watched a clip I had
to shut it off forgive me I don't know
what radio show it is but she's sitting
there she goes and she's trying to get
the black vote and she they ask you
what's something you always carry around
with you and she said hot sauce what
they the Clintons are the [ __ ] I
swear to God can't you just see both of
them on a used-car lot doing one of
those cheesy local commercials who they
are the [ __ ] devil
I remember when Hillary Clinton ran for
[ __ ] Senate after eight years of
being in the White House the [ __ ]
Yankees had won four World Series she
never showed up never said a [ __ ]
thing and then all of a sudden she's
running for [ __ ] Senate in New York
shows up with a brand-new Yankee hat
guys I've always been a Yankee fan that
this big grin like I said it now they're
gonna like me this is how out of touch
she is she literally thinks that she
just has to say I carry around hot sauce
and all black people gonna be like oh oh
[ __ ] oh I can relate to that what's she
gonna do next
you're gonna go to [ __ ] Chinatown
which I always carry around soy sauce go
down south you know I love guns and my
cousin's sorry sorry I should have said
that um hot rods I've always liked hot
rods [ __ ] shameless this is the thing
about like when you're at her level of
[ __ ] wealth which is really I don't
know how you explain it you know when
her husband you know had the highest
office in a public office and you only
is president you only make for 500 grand
a year somehow they threw that daughter
at three million dollar wedding I mean
how does the math work there they are
the [ __ ] that she is the [ __ ] devil
I'm telling you you know oh my god what
a [ __ ] selection this year can you
[ __ ] believe this [ __ ] a reality show
star you know who's sitting there with
that [ __ ] I don't know what the other
guy's name is and they're talking about
the size of their hands they're having a
sizee a dick debate running for office
you got Hillary you [ __ ] write it
I'll say it
doesn't give a [ __ ] this is what I got
to be honest with you why I like
Republicans better than Democrats
Republicans at least have the decency to
just show too openly show you that they
don't give a [ __ ] about you and
Democrats they actually try to act like
they give a [ __ ] how people about people
who work for a [ __ ] living they don't
they're the same [ __ ] people they
just lie about you know I swear to God
if Bernie Sanders would just [ __ ] go
the whole way you know what I mean don't
stop and cool wait you got to go all the
way to Baghdad with these [ __ ]
bankers okay that's what you got to do
you got to tip over the statue and you
got to have all those top-level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope that's the
only way to see you got to start over
again
that's my candidate
none of them are saying that so it's
over and I know you'd think it bill
you don't know [ __ ] and you read
conspiracy theory and you know when I
say too that you're absolutely right
okay all right let's move on that was uh
that was uh that was political comedy
right there if you if you're wondering
what that was supposed to be it's ghost
a little italy what do you always have
in your purse a jar of marinara thought
who's your favorite singer Dean Martin
oh my god did you see the host she
looked like she rolled her eyes I don't
want to put like [ __ ] on her that that's
what she [ __ ] did that's how out of
touch she is Hillary Clinton thinks
black all black people walk around with
hot sauce in their purse because white
people don't know how to season food I'm
not saying there aren't some black
people did through that you know what I
mean but you know that would also be
people who aren't white who look at
white people and think we're all in the
upper 1% standing on a yacht shooting
the [ __ ] with one of the Kennedys and
they're [ __ ] weird in Brent inbred
dentition
I don't understood the Kennedys I they
they're from like the nose up they're
really good-looking people great hair
you know nice [ __ ] big five head you
know looks great on TV decent eyes you
know and then you just get to that you
get to those I mean it was kidding oh
they look like from the No
down they look like Clint Howard I don't
know what it is there's something going
on with that family you can't you notice
is they still look ethnic if you look at
if you look at like like white people
from like like look at Joe DiMaggio you
know he's probably considered a
good-looking guy that guy is [ __ ]
dick I don't know what happened once
everybody got all mixed up like all the
[ __ ] Nationals got mixed up like you
know started streamlining the looks and
people are way better looking now don't
you think then when you look back in the
day I mean Jesus Christ babe rule
everyone so Lou Gehrig was a
good-looking guy you know what I mean
but Babe Ruth that guy was a mess Joe
DiMaggio mess I guess they weren't all
bad looking I know I'm just saying when
you look at the [ __ ] back then like an
Italian guy looked a hundred percent
[ __ ] in town you know something when
I went to Italy they were better look in
the back then I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was we allegedly had better food back
then people were shorter I don't know
what I was do you ever notice that when
you look back and when you really look
at those old pictures I love looking at
old pictures and it's like that George
Carlin bit when you look at it on
picture and you're like everybody in
that picture is dead
and for some reason in a morbid way it's
like fascinating when I look at those
old pictures I just that's what I think
a god damnit there was some [ __ ] ugly
ass people you know and you know was a
game change it was uh three things polio
vaccine penicillin and braces those
three [ __ ] things could just hide so
many [ __ ] imperfections you know what
I mean don't you get braces Jesus Christ
if you just brush your [ __ ] teeth and
remotely keep yourself in shape you know
you throw on some nice clothes people
have no idea where you came from you
know back in the day people they saw it
on you your teeth told the whole [ __ ]
story you'd smile of you like I I can
see you're gonna have to perk you
Llosa's
you live in a damp dank [ __ ]
apartment with no [ __ ] windows you
saw it in their [ __ ] teeth right I
don't know but I heard what's-his-face
JP Morgan had like rosacea though said
oh you say they had it all over his face
he was just all [ __ ] angry those
old-school rich guys you know used to
walk around with top hats it's like the
penguin horror walking down the street
is this a podcast anymore I mean what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about let me let me
do something advertising here and then
I'll I'll get two more babbling here in
a moment all right hot sauce
shameless [ __ ] shameless she looks
inbred her [ __ ] teeth there's
something going on with Herman this some
girl you see how Bill Clinton collapsed
now it's like he's like a marionette
puppet he has his mouth open uh that's
how he made it but that smiling with his
mouth open oh I've gotta fix it I'm
gonna fix everything
how you doing Coleman later Oh
all right on it everybody on it this
company the great Joe Rogan this is his
company here speaking of getting into
shape a lot of people when they get in
shape what do they do they do setups
right they do [ __ ] they do pull-ups
they do push-ups they do all the upper
body stuff and they walk around with
their [ __ ] chicken legs but still
you're always working on the outside of
your body what about the inside man well
thank God this on it alpha brain instant
from on it is a delicious all-natural
stimulant free drink mix that helps
support memory focus and processing
speed the Boston Center from memory
conducted a double-blind study showing
its effectiveness that's pretty
impressive huh it's a secret weapon of
pro athletes like I'm gonna [ __ ] these
names up Bode Miller Brian Cushing and
Jonathan caves but anyone can benefit
from the effects of alpha brain instant
speaking of that what about the blues
huh up three games to one
Wow all right simple mix is a stick Bo
simply mix is a stick packet of alpha
brain instant into a water bottle o
simply mix
a stick oh my god I need this [ __ ] you
know what I should do I should start
taking this [ __ ] and then you can hear
how much better I read the copy then you
guys would fast-forward to it through it
because there'd be no reason to listen
to me [ __ ] this up simply mix a stick
packet of alpha brain instant into a
water bottle and start feeling the
effects immediately it's non-gmo nice
gluten free sweet stimulant free made of
natural ingredients and most importantly
it works and as a special offer for my
listeners you can try alpha brain
instant for free by going to on it o n
ni tea on it calm / / that's onn i
t-dot-com / / to get your free sample of
alpha brain instant now you know what I
think I got to do that I'm worried that
that would [ __ ] up everything that makes
me funny you know we know who's kidding
who most imprison ye laugh it makes them
a [ __ ] dope but what if I just take
it I'm smart for a few weeks and then
you guys see that it works and then I
just stop taking it I go back to being
stupid again then you guys could send me
emails okay bill remember when you will
[ __ ] smack alright score big score
big everybody you're paying too much for
tickets between all the mock-ups and
lists and last minute convenience
charges which aren't convenient except
for the people get the money even
print-at-home fees you end up paying
courtside prices for nosebleed seats and
that's [ __ ] scored big is here to
change that did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go unsold and did you
know here there's a place to get these
seats at a huge savings
it's called score big score big works
directly with your favorite teams and
artists to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices only with score big
can you name a ticket price and be
guaranteed to pay below box-office up to
60% off here's what you do one go to
score big calm or download the new score
big a point for your iPhone and find the
event and seats you want to make an
offer with score Biggs name a ticket
price feature 9 sorry 3 get an instant
answer and save up to 60% of your
tickets never any fees and shipping is
always free you can count on unbeatable
prices and great seats and when you're
in great seats you actually enjoy the
game or show all the
or next time you go to see any game of
show go to score big first and see how
much you can save for the easiest way to
save on tickets download the new score
big app for your iPhone enter promo code
burr at the checkout and you'll save an
extra twenty bucks for your first ticket
purchase no iPhone no problem get $20
off online at score big calm let's score
big calm promo code burr high score big
calm promo code burr I still don't get
that I really don't I don't understand
that that the [ __ ] 40% of the tickets
go unsold so like when the Patriots
everybody wants the Patriots taking tell
me 40% of those tickets go unsold I
really don't understand that part of it
this is why I lose advertising I
shouldn't just question to a question if
they don't just read it go into
advertising mode ball and branch as you
set out to improve yourself there is one
simple thing you could do every day to
help you you be your best at every
situation and that's getting a good
night's sleep Boleyn branch delivers the
rest you need wrapped up in their super
comfortable luxury linens and they do it
right there the first betting company to
be Fairtrade certified which means that
your sheets come from the work of happy
hands not sweatshops nice somebody who
finally cares about other human beings
nice and beautiful packaging made
entirely from recycled and some
sustainable materials this company's
doing it right you can only get their
sheets in one place that's bowl and
branch calm well you know you're paying
for quality and not to start department
store overhead you also know that no
crying child made it at 3 o'clock in the
morning you're getting thousands of
thousand dollar sheets for just a couple
of hundred bucks go online to bowl
that's bol el and branch calm like cliff
and they'll let you transfer a defense
and they let you try them risk-free for
30 days if you don't love them you can
send it back you have nothing to lose
and it gets even better go to Boleyn
branch calm today for 20% off your
entire order sheets towels blankets
duvet covers everything extra bonus
points I said duvet properly Plus free
shipping and all their products come
beautifully packaged in their signature
box let's go to Boleyn branch calm today
for 20% off your entire order and use
promo code burr Boleyn branch comm promo
code bar hey Bolden branch comp all
promo code burr jesus-fucking-christ I
still have two more no I can't do two
I'll do two more later let's go back to
here the [ __ ] how about the st. Louis
Blues me Louie Louie meet me at the fair
I miss game three I was convinced that
once they blew game two that that was
[ __ ] it but I was actually able to
watch Game four and I like my nature I
actually turned it on mid second mid
second period and I got to tell you
these are not your [ __ ] dad's st.
Louis Blues you know they were down they
came back they went ahead they just they
just it's actually you're watching
Chicago losing their composure Chicago
trying to draw them into fights and
stuff like that it's unbelievable now
I'm not counting I kind of am counting
Chicago I don't think that they're going
to come back from this one I think st.
Louis Blues are got their eye on the
prize or whatever I think they got this
series and just the way they're playing
just all this [ __ ] that they I've seen
them go through all these years and
never answer the bell and just [ __ ]
implode and lose the [ __ ] serious
there this team does not do that and
it's [ __ ] great to see but it's also
great watching the Blackhawks to like
you know what I love about them is you
can see like they're they're like
Patrick King and you can't you see the
guy gives a [ __ ] that's the win one
championship and then be like yeah you
know [ __ ] whatever but that's the
guys who give a [ __ ] and they want to
win as many as they can he can't put a
price on those guys so as much as it's
kind of bizarre watching Chicago being
down three to one after their success
over the last five six years
watching how much they give a [ __ ] who
is it like I'm so bad with the names now
I'm so out of a [ __ ] loop who was the
guy that Patrick sharp he got [ __ ]
traded what was the guy was [ __ ]
cross-checking everybody at the end of
the game it ever is it go that guy's a
dirty piece
it's like no he isn't he gives a [ __ ] he
gives a [ __ ] you know going in the
penalty box he's [ __ ] screaming at
people dropping the f-bomb I loved every
second of it oh man you know I you know
what I shouldn't even say the Blackhawks
arrived because you know the [ __ ]
Blackhawks right now I like there's no
[ __ ] way these guys are gonna beat us
next game you know that that's what they
say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] all we need to do is win
this next one get it back into our
building and then the pressure will be
on them that all [ __ ] if we don't we
don't win this one then now we're
looking at a game seven that's how
[ __ ] up three-to-one is you always
think like ah man we was sitting pretty
and it's just like no we're not we're
not we have to win this next game if we
lose this next game then all of a sudden
all of the [ __ ] pressure is dumped on
us for the next for the rest of the
series
it's I don't know it's [ __ ] uh I
don't know I actually believe it or not
as bad as I am at math like seven games
series numbers like fascinate me like if
you go down Oh to like the Boston
Celtics and it's this weird thing well
if you just think look but just down two
games to none it doesn't seem that bad a
hole to crawl out of but when you do the
math and be like we have to win four of
the remaining five games you're like
what the [ __ ] do you do that and you
know when I say the 86 Mets because I
remember that we won the first two games
in New York City and I was just like oh
my god all we got to do is win two out
of the next four they got to win four
out of the next I'm sorry we got to win
two out of the next five that's all we
had to do all we had to do was with two
out of the next five they had to win
four out of five and they they came back
and they won Game three and four in
Fenway if I remember this correctly the
first two games wasn't it down there I
don't know I can't remember that I just
mind we won the first two games and I
want to say they came here and then what
that would they were here then we were
down there
no Game six and seven were down there
Game six certainly was and seven was
wait it went how daddy [ __ ] ago goes
home home away away home oh wait home
no maybe was this three in a row in
Boston maybe was three in a row and
bought they might have gone to three -
oh god what is [ __ ] that we won Game
five we're like finally we had Game six
when we blew that and then we blew up
three nothing game seven eight competing
gonna be over just like [ __ ] that so
I really shouldn't say this is over all
I'm saying is you got to watch Game five
you watch how if the [ __ ] Blackhawks
come out I know that they've lost a lot
of guys but they still got tapes they
still got [ __ ] Duncan Kane
they still got [ __ ] and the other guy
and the other [ __ ] guy right I got
enough guys left they're like we're not
losing this [ __ ] game blues you know
what I think it's a must-win after me
just saying this is how [ __ ]
wishy-washy I am after I just say I
think the Blues got this one I'm now
thinking like thank God they got to
close him out they gotta close him on
Jesus Christ I hope they're Newt
Gingrich looking coach [ __ ] gives him
that speech speaking of which the Boston
Celtics I'm calling it right now
Hotlanta before you get too [ __ ]
excited I'm going Joe Willie Namath
right now I guaran-fucking-tee you the
Boston Celtics you're gonna go into the
garden there's gonna be all those
championship banners hanging from the
[ __ ] rafters right all of a sudden
you're not gonna have that cool breeze
blowing over your head like you feel
down in your Omni Center whatever the
[ __ ] the Hawks play right from your lack
of goddamn championships down there the
Boston Celtics I am me who doesn't play
hoop who isn't a professional athlete
who cannot read out loud is
guaran-fucking-tee the Boston Celtics
are gonna win Game three I'm calling it
right [ __ ] now if I don't understand
why I have to wait till [ __ ] Friday
I'm actually gonna be on the road what
are you gonna be bill I'm gonna be in
st. Louis the original home of the
Atlanta Hawks the st. Louis Hawks and
who beat him in 1958 for the NBA
championship the Boston Celtics
you like that the synergies all gonna be
there they're going back to Boston where
all those championship banners are old
Billy red face is gonna be in st. Louis
the original home of the Hawks where he
beat him in 1958 and I'm telling you
right now you take all your money you
steal from your mother you put it on the
Celtics and I guarantee you you're gonna
come away a winner and if you lose I
don't want to hear your crying to me
because I take no responsibility for
this all right
you're responsible for your own [ __ ]
actions are the most [ __ ] up thought I
had the most [ __ ] [ __ ] up thought
the other night and I yeah buddy have
like a [ __ ] up thought and then you
did you go to google it and you're
thinking like a bunch of people gonna
agree with you and then you just like no
you know what I'm just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know that postpartum depression you
know women have a baby and then they
just [ __ ] have this unbelievable
level of depression i whatever for
whatever reason was hearing a story
about it and I was listening and
listening and I was thinking like you
know what as much as that is a thing I
bet 17% I don't know why I came to that
number but in my head 17 percent of
women that get postpartum depression
they're just selfish that's what I was
thinking like it's a real thing for 83
percent of them but 17 percent of them
are just mad now that they have a kid
and they can't go out and go do jello
shots whatever they want to and then
they're just being a bunch of [ __ ]
babies about it that's what old not dr.
burr here was thinking and then I looked
it up and there was all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] about dumb men like me that think
[ __ ] like that so you know what's great
is I only thought that thought for about
three minutes and then I went and looked
it up and I was like oh all right I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I wonder if there's
any mail if there's mail if male Kick
and males have that [ __ ] did I even
bother doing studies they don't give a
[ __ ] about us they just they don't we
died eight years before women on average
and they they nobody really cares they
why does this keep happening they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah that's a guy make
another one all right
mail post partum oh my god there is this
fax about men's depression Oh give me a
[ __ ] break you didn't go through it
he's [ __ ] sort of physical thing I
can't watch the game anymore
men's depression research is only
beginning to understand men's unique
experiences of depression yeah why why
do you think that is because we're told
to shut the [ __ ] up and plow through it
blah blah blah blah blah research is
lagging even further as for PP and D
whatever that is I don't know what that
is postpartum Notre Dame I don't have no
idea in terms of depression in general
if you're a man you're more likely than
a woman to try and hide your depression
or to withdraw from others this only
worsens your system all paternal post
postnatal depression oh my god used to
see the pictures of these [ __ ] people
this guy's sitting there he's clearly an
actor and he's just looking down holding
his like pinching his nose between his
eyes okay in this picture we want you to
look depressed all right you know that
statue the thinker okay I want you to do
the same pose but don't think I want you
to pinch the top of your nose that's it
that's it
close your eyes think of something
painful and alright that's it here's 50
bucks go get yourself a doughnuts
classic symptoms of depression depressed
sad mood all right let's I'm gonna take
this test
depress sad mood no I don't have that
loss of interests or pleasure I don't
have that either significant waste loss
or gain [ __ ] I'm putting on weight I
have this [ __ ] trouble sleeping and over
sleeping oh no I thought it was the
booze restless feeling and inability to
sit still or slow down no I definitely
got that fatigue loss of energy to are
tired all the time
absolutely I thought that was because I
drink every night you only get four
hours sleep worthless or guilty feelings
check impaired concentration and
difficulty making decisions I got half
of that recurrent thoughts of death or
suicide yep
the suicide option is always right there
right it's such an easy one you just
like you know or I could just kill
myself yeah but then you know what if
one of the Bruins rebuilded I miss it
you know what I think I'll stick around
alright let me let me read a little more
of this the the advertising here and
I'll gracefully get the [ __ ] out of here
for anything all right
the undies Biondi you had a mother
[ __ ] kid but who do biondi's Biondi
blew it inter that's what you did and
now you feel bad cuz she's your man
[ __ ] man caves got a baby crib and
you wanna booze every time you see that
kid no matter how much you [ __ ] love
it
you still what a booze thank God your
[ __ ] balls are dry we really beat it
alright me undies whether you're wearing
a suit or sweaty you spend almost 24
hours a day in your underwear but
instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes your underwear is probably
boring me undies is here to change that
everybody every pair of me undies is
made from their sustainable source modal
a fabric that is twice as soft as cotton
says the makers of Modell nothing can
describe the fit and feel of me undies
but once you try them on you'll
understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear and
if you don't love the first pair of me
undies they're free no questions asked
my undies has dozens of styles and
limited edition prints to help you make
a statement with your underwear
whether anyone can see them or not
remembers remember Superman
alright shipping is free in the US and
Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair
with the me undies subscription plan get
the subscription or a single pair
get 20% off your first order when you go
to me undies comm slash bird that's me
undies comm / / for 20% off your first
order hi my undies dot-com / / alright
the last one LegalZoom 5 things you can
count on when using LegalZoom for you
dude how much do you [ __ ] yourself that
you gotta have a subscription to get
underwear good lord
you [ __ ] wet dream Wally allright
LegalZoom 5 things you can count on when
using LegalZoom for your business number
1 numeral reliability more than a
reliability more than a million people
have already trusted LegalZoom to start
help start their businesses in
corporations LLC's nonprofits DBAs and
more use LegalZoom to get started the
right way number 2 experience you can
count on LegalZoom for all the details
they've been helping all types of
business owners for 15 years number 3
helpful support they have the right
people standing by ready to help you
with your questions all based in the US
do you think I'm pretty
of course you are says LegalZoom number
4 numero cuatro legal advice Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm so they built a network
of independent attorneys available in 48
states you'll get answers to your legal
questions and they can review supplier
contracts employment laws and help with
most of the day-to-day situations that
pop up and finally number 5
uno dos tres cuatro Cinco the block top
sake number 5 no surprises Legal Zoom
provides complete transparency with
upfront pricing and customer reviews for
the hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee
make the smart choice for your
businesses at legalzoom.com today and
don't forget to enter ber at checkout to
save even more at legalzoom.com there
you go alright and you know what that's
the first half of the podcast here and I
want to thank all the African Americans
who are listening to this and I want you
to know that
you know my favorite guilty pleasure is
soul food any Asians listening I don't
know I I really respect mixed martial
arts I'm gonna try to appeal to
everybody Germans I don't hold you
responsible you picked one bad guy you
know you had a bad [ __ ] couple of
years all of a sudden the wrong guy got
in there you happens eventually it
happens to every country I mean I think
at this point hasn't there been a mass
murdering maniac every you know haven't
the Germans made enough unbelievable
sports to dance
Portia's you know no you don't think so
they got nice clothes so don't they I
don't [ __ ] it up anyways I don't want to
do Thank You Jeremy i briefed you guys
during the World Cup how about that it's
just funny I like listening like there's
something funny to me of a bunch of
Germans in public in a stadium you know
singing along and [ __ ] no there's no way
that's never not going to be creepy
anymore so there's just something
hilarious about so I always root for you
guys to get to the later rounds you know
and as you like when Germany and
whatever they're playing like Brazil
it's impossible to not picture the ghost
of [ __ ] Adolf Hitler sitting up there
hoping for a do-over
even when Jesse Owens embarrassed them
and you know you think he's not up there
that's two out of three yeah all right
please enjoy this music and we're gonna
start pulling in place some Greatest
Hits from Monday morning podcasts gone
by thank you everybody have a great
weekend you [ __ ] and once again thank
you to everybody who's been watching f
is for family we're having a great time
writing these things and last night we
had a great event with Netflix Netflix
keep it weird they did this thing they
hijacked that hippy [ __ ] thing yeah
their corporation you know what I mean
they do want a Hillary Clinton does you
know what's the one thing you have on
you at all times Netflix so I always
have a bag
weed in my purse man everybody's running
for office all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
hello what's going on over Monday
morning card fest and as you can tell by
the sound of my voice I got about two
hours sleep last night I am sitting in
the continental terminal in Newark
Airport
I just had an omelet [ __ ] three
cheese and I've got them piece of toast
and I was trying not to get mad at the
guy making the [ __ ] eggs but I did
order toast with it you know and I don't
know if this has been your experience
but my experience is when I go into a
breakfast establishment every time you
order something hang on a second I wish
this distance okay thank you let me grab
another dump it out of that I got it out
of there
we know I know we know we have to get on
the airplane shut up we all old people
who have a limp to get on first
we know how it works shut up okay anyway
so when I order anytime I go out to a
breakfast place right i order toast yeah
I get toast with your eggs you know if
you don't you're a [ __ ] communist
okay go for some [ __ ] reason they
always make the goddamn eggs first and
then they go oh [ __ ] I didn't make the
toast
so then either they give you the eggs
and you eat the [ __ ] eggs without the
toast which once again is unamerican eat
the toast with the [ __ ] eggs are
supposed to arrive at the same time okay
so you either just give you the goddamn
eggs and eat the [ __ ] eggs and then I
go oh by the way here's your toast
you know everybody ordered like a hot
fudge sundae and it gave you the [ __ ]
ice cream and then once you're done
eating your ice cream then they came
over with the with the [ __ ] with like a
shot of hot fudge you know and you hold
your nose you get a [ __ ] throw it down
like Jagermeister you know so this
[ __ ] douche bag makes the goddamn
eggs alright and then realize oh you are
toast with that yeah I had toast with
you read the next line on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] lip you would have seen it you
know it's not like it's a lot of reading
it's not war and peace it says three
cheese omelet and underneath it it said
white toast right so what does this guy
do he ops to keep the [ __ ] eggs with
him while he waits for the toast to be
done and he's making some sort of turkey
sandwich and needless to say I get I get
the egg I was this loud [ __ ] moment
gonna be screwing her cellphone near me
you know I tried to pick a [ __ ] part
of the airport where no one would come
okay
she get on the tracks is got a lot of no
person an attractive um you know enemy
were they doing the reunion up in 1940
Olympics anyways yes that's what this
[ __ ] guy does right he gives me my
long story short I get mags mags a
[ __ ] cold and now my toast is hot as
hell and you know that's an omen
you know what I mean - goddamn home on
the pile of [ __ ] day it's gonna go
you know when you can't get your
breakfast to coincide on the temperature
just really annoying but you know oh
Jesus Christ
we'll pick it up after sayonara
what did she even say aging to people
with really foreign sounding names
I like oh she said their last name too
is if there's another guy named Barack
Baba in the [ __ ] Airport um oh Jesus
I'm gonna move oh god it's not a special
announcement when you have an
announcement every three seconds you
know Oh should I keep my bag with me I
was going to leave it down the [ __ ]
Street for you cannot take a pistol onto
the plane even if you're in first class
this is what I can't bear these [ __ ]
announcements like I'm some goddamn
child every five seconds telling me what
I can and can't
do well just tell me what I can't do
that's what I don't like that little hot
stewardess that no their planes soduku
huh trying to attract a man show the
cheese the classy flight attendant she's
not a sky [ __ ] and she's into puzzles
probably means she doesn't drink but
you'd be surprised I bet she gives a
good [ __ ] oh look at me give doing a
little sex joke I just stay away from
that material because it's too easy to
get a laugh are you chuckling in your
cubicle right now people all right your
collective cubicle anyways that's my
[ __ ] three cheese omelet with the
delayed white toast story slash
Tourette's over the [ __ ]
announcements if you're doin my page
this is the Monday morning podcast
hosted by me next week I'll have a guest
house I'll be sick and let some feature
I call up as myself and he'll complain
about the bagel he bought so anyways I
do one of these every week I answer
questions and I you know people send me
questions and all speaking of that I
want to apologize to the person that I
trashed last week for asking me where
exactly they send the questions to
evidently somebody hacked my account and
get rid of the place where it says bad
friends send a message so I imagine that
would be confusing even though he did
still send me an email but I want to
thank the two or three people gave me
the heads up I'm trying to think who the
[ __ ] would hack my account so I couldn't
add friends short list would probably be
other comedians oh hang on a second hang
down another telling the Asian people
what they can and can't do when they get
on the people on the flight no shop in
chopstick allowed in the common area you
know that was not only racist it was
also hacky chopsticks Billy couldn't
come up with a more original [ __ ]
artifact from the Orient you know what I
can't I'm actually at a loss
chopstix these are the hacky references
I have from the Far East chopsticks
sushi such a kind of same thing they go
hand in hand kabuki and then that one
guy who stood in front of that tank in
Tiananmen Square Oh
Buddhist monks protesting whatever the
[ __ ] it is China's doing to him you know
China's doing to Tibet they're doing the
same thing with these [ __ ] people in
the airport of doing over the
announcements that's what it's like
living at the bed constant announcements
over your head they're all playing uh no
Tibetan monk no Gregorian chant from
12:30 to 1:30 alright was that offensive
enough I hope so okay uh anyway so
people send me whatever they send me
questions and I answer them for the best
of my ability people send me conspiracy
theory somebody sent me a great link but
I'm sitting here in the airport and I
can't open that [ __ ] without having to
pay for [ __ ] internet which is I
refuse to do because I'm already doing
it I'm already doing it on my goddamn
[ __ ] place out in California but
whoever it was it something that thing I
really wish I could say and do that
conspiracy theory thing was hilarious I
had all the stuff about 9/11 Hitler and
what I loved about it was the usual the
usual categories of conspiracy theory
but somehow everything came back to
blaming Jewish people literally to the
point that this website was actually
trying to suggest that Jewish people
were actually financially backing Hitler
and his whole movement I mean I don't
know it was just [ __ ] it was
hilarious oh [ __ ]
yeah another announcement how do people
get lost in the airport you know what I
mean how do you get separated like this
place is on fire and everybody's [ __ ]
running everybody had cell phones I
don't understand the need to still page
somebody
engine in the convoys and civil rivers
whose focus Philip always a quarterback
for flunking San Diego okay I can't even
come up with a fake name
I said Phillips second I was a good fake
name and then I panic and went with
rivers Philip Rivers the hot-headed
quarterback oh no no no that's not the
hot but I had a quarterback that's his
that's the braggadocious one who is the
original who is that [ __ ] quarterback
for the charges was screaming at that
reporter [ __ ] was his name number one
draft Ryan Leaf wait I so many you
broads out there who listen to this
podcast and you're not into sports you
still should go on Google Google Ryan
Leaf rya n le a fo8 google it and you
know if you thought your husband was an
[ __ ] and at it you know and soda
would berate you you guys say when he
yells at this reporter it's awesome
no one gave off the date-rape lot better
than Ryan Leaf one of the great
characters or the great busts in NFL
history huh anybody else was Tony manda
rich let his [ __ ] name who's a guy be
incredible bloke that 400-pound guy on
roids the Packers picked up he showed up
with his muscles in his acne and I don't
know what happened Dexter Manley gave
him an uppercut and just ended his
career I never really did [ __ ] always
okay Todd Marinovich that's the other
guy that's a guy thought I'd confused it
with a guy from USC whose dad was making
him run for 40s as a toddler I was least
timing him in the 40 I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about this point a
math asleep so anyways let's get on with
the podcast questions oh but before I do
fans of my radio show that I do with Joe
DeRosa who's in my top 46 on myspace if
you look he's the second one over we do
a radio show in XM 202 once a month
comes out on a Saturday the next one we
have is going to be on Saturday
a May the 24th we just pre-recorded it
we had a great show me and Joe both have
incredible tempers and we scream at each
other and that's the show and actually
the shows that guest we had an anger
management therapist come on to analyze
our anger and trying to figure out
whether a couple of psychos and I got am
it man she got right around my defenses
she got in real close she was like
writing my grill emotionally and I was
[ __ ] uncomfortable but I think it
made for some good radio so please check
that out and what else I'm going to be
at Zanies in Chicago on May 14th through
that Sunday I think I don't have my
calendar in front of me it's going to be
real sketchy but the date should be
right there you can click on it and find
out where I'm going to be case you don't
understand how [ __ ] computers work
all right what else I got
Caroline's Caroline's comedy club in New
York City would be there from May 29th
June 1st and Joe DeRosa will be
featuring and in June I'm going to be in
[ __ ] my act goodnight comedy clubs
Raleigh North Carolina and I'll be at
the punchline in Atlanta Georgia
Hotlanta if the brothers call it
wouldn't hell I'm gonna be there
something like [ __ ] June 19th or
something I don't know I don't have the
stuff in front of me okay all right I'm
in a bad mood right ate cold eggs and
[ __ ] hot toast it's enough to make
anybody [ __ ] irritable god I can't
wait to get old and dressed like that
look at that [ __ ] mess get on a pink
hoodie with lime-green slacks Caprice
lacks that cover all the varicose veins
down to her calves and no socks and then
some sort of Michael Jackson loafers
so the gallery looks like a I think he
murdered his wife yeah now if I get a
bottle of peroxide you ever notice
anybody murders their wife they always
go with the peroxide then I talked about
that last week and I think like that's
going to help you [ __ ] blend in lady
over here with the pantsuit you know I
should talk right now I have on track
sneakers track sneakers is that actually
a [ __ ] brand of sneakers undone order
this they're raw silver with a red Nike
swoosh I was probably sewn on by a
[ __ ] three-year-old in Bangladesh and
I have on jeans and a suede leather coat
yeah I guess I'm looking like an [ __ ]
to it but if another person sitting here
some up-and-coming comedian doing the
podcast and are actually making fun of
me
look at that [ __ ] Aryan looking
psycho over there why would you wear a
[ __ ] suede jacket with some track
sneakers unless you stole a jacket and
you had to get the [ __ ] out of there
quickly fun enough about theories all
right let's get on with the podcast
questions of the week okay
Phil you said you love [ __ ] that is not
meant to be funny but you find it to be
that way we try to read that sentence in
a pace that'll actually makes sense that
had really awkward pauses in it you know
I mean like if you you take the most
basic sentence and you pause in a weird
area people don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about and I think I
just sort of read it and an even tempo
wrong team wrong PCI bill you see it you
said you love [ __ ] that is not meant to
be funny but you find it to be that way
see now makes sense even made sense to
me
I got lost the first time I read it just
why not read because I just get confused
and it just really holds a mirror up to
my stupidity and and I'm alone it's a
very scary moment okay so what is your
favorite movie that you find funny that
is not meant to be funny there's so much
[ __ ] I can't even start you know what
this is really the little Stewart is
Haven over here now there's three
stewardess just sitting there this looks
like the beginning of a point
you know like all I need to do is just
walk into frame and next thing you know
it's going to be our own baby okay what
is my favorite movie that I find funny
that's meant to be funny there's too
many of them you know Roadhouse you
never seen Roadhouse some of you
youngsters out there you got to see it
stars Patrick Swayze I believe that's
why I have his picture there Roadhouse
is basically about a bay a [ __ ] [ __ ] my
cell phone's going to die again damn it
let me get quickly here Roadhouse is
about a rough-and-tumble bar and they
can't seem to get control over it so
they hire this bouncer from I don't know
where but he basically has a reputation
on the bouncer circuit that's what I
love about it like there's this bouncer
circuit like comedians the only mean
like people out there like going oh did
you hear Chris Rock's new hour and 45
like there's like the Chris Rock of
bouncers out there you know like who's
your favorite bouncer like up-and-coming
bouncers have a favorite [ __ ] bouncer
so anyway they bring in they bring in
Patrick Swayze all 138 pounds of him
with his feathered mullet to come in and
clean this [ __ ] bar up and people my
favorite students in there is when after
he gets hired he gets into his
mercedes-benz and the plane is music and
nnnn and the showing like I'm putting on
the brave on glasses horseshit at one
point he slides it hits that taped it
like that was some [ __ ] amazing I
guess it was an amazing option at that
point and there's that moment and the
moment when he leans against the bar and
this really bad white blues music is
playing and he's doing this weird sort
of [ __ ] head nod to the music that's
supposed to imply that he's tough I
don't know my cell phone's going to die
I can't explain it but a Roadhouse any
movie that has Clint Howard in it and I
signed Fox News to be [ __ ] absolutely
hilarious just the fact that people
actually look at it like it's an actual
news
and these people are journalists and and
you know Bill O'Reilly always [ __ ]
hilarious screaming at people with the
and then just making over-the-top
comments like the Second Amendment is
the most important amendment out there
the right to bear arms if anything
taught us that it was Hurricane Katrina
he actually [ __ ] said that and then a
nice drum and then started talking about
hooligans to kind of cover his tracks
but he got the message out there all
right let me answer this next question
really quickly before my cell phone dies
I was wondering if you're into comic
books or how you [ __ ] or nobody cares
your announcement right pay attention on
the compost okay why don't you repeat it
a third time all right
I was wondering if you're in comic books
and if you were at all
blah blah blah who your favorite ones I
was in the spider-man and it was
actually one of my favorite comic books
as a kid it was a comic book for
spider-man and this guy Power Man
this black this black superhero and he
had a you know this yellow shirt you
know they was dressed very flamboyant
Lee I saw there was a fire in a building
and he saved the fire I'm the fireman it
was just a really cool one and just like
the movies they make about comics and
it's no I don't because most of them end
up being chick flicks you know you
should ask that question to Keith
Robinson because he's the one really
[ __ ] cult that oh it's not special
not a special announcement is every five
[ __ ] seconds no one's going to
abandon their luggage okay alright it's
time to wrap this [ __ ] podcast up
alright I'm going to go over there go
hit on these stewardesses and see if I
can make that fantasy come true can you
even hear me
anyways I want to thank everybody for
listening to the Monday morning podcast
and setting in the questions please keep
sending me the conspiracy theory and all
the tech stuff and I just want to thank
everybody who came out to helium comedy
club out in Philadelphia I had a had a
great time down there and
no Chloe nothing there's actually great
crowds actually really uh crowds dude
who knew right I had a great time so
thanks to everybody who came out and uh
sorry this podcast is so short short and
sweet but I'm going to run out of
batteries here so I'll talk to all you
guys next week
the link is back up so please keep
sending me the questions are everybody
[Music]
you